[Music]
you guys know about license plates and
how much they can cost tell them steve
87 wait don't you have like a custom
plate i never got a custom plate before
yeah custom plates yeah i got customers
about the digital ones
uh
these are like yeah there's digital ones
i'm talking like old license plates that
wow
talking old license plates that have
very specific things on them like uh if
you go on craigslist or an offer up you
just type license plates you're going to
get a bunch of like random old plates
that are being sold for like ridiculous
oh yeah because some people just buy
license plates and then they like hang
in their garage and stuff like that i
see them at like thrift stores sometimes
in california you can register any plate
even if it's super old so you know like
for a bit they had these like sunset
plates or they had black plates yeah the
blue ones
oh the blue one the blue and yellow yeah
so you can't get those new but you can
get an old blue plate and register that
so people will pay money to get those
like old plates
there is a specific california license
plate right it has only two letters on
it mm
and other than that there's only 12
other plates in existence on the
registry that have two letters in a row
and nothing else how much do you think
this plate is selling for it's probably
a lot
because the mexican mafia probably wants
that one the most mexican mafia so it's
like your life who else would want mm a
million one million i mean who else
would want to play like that the mexican
mafia no the m m company yeah yeah no
way yeah yeah or eminem donuts is that
who wants it so it's no not at all yeah
who's on the bid
it's kind of like so different in
different countries as well like uh i
think in the emirates
uh the richer you were the lower the
digits were on your plate so a lot of
like places will want to find the plate
with the lowest uh number like it'd be
11 or 12. so like only royalty has
plates like that but uh yeah like in
dubai yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so those
though like i think previously the
highest that's pretty baller
yeah those are like some pretty
expensive plates but here in california
there's a guy who unearthed his double m
plate and he's selling it for one more
guest three hundred thousand dollars
twenty three thousand dollars five
million dollars twenty four point three
million get the [ __ ] out who's gonna pay
for that twenty four point three minutes
what's with them who gives a [ __ ] max
come on and also like how many people
are aware of this it's the rarity it's
because there's no it's kind of like
domain names you know when you get a
dome like let's say you have mm.com and
you just sit on it for years and then
finally you're like you know what i'm to
sell this it's going to be like a
ludicrous amount right but plates are
even are even better because you're
going to like disney this specific plate
not only is it being sold for 24.3
million but part of what gives it that
value is on the other side what do you
think's there there's a picture of a
woman's ass your woman's ass yes which
woman
cindy lauper oh get the [ __ ] out
but it's a [ __ ] qr code which goes to
nft grand theft auto account thank you
really
yeah it's a you get an nft certification
that this is your place wow that's way
though yeah way though so what is it 24
point what million dollars 4.3 million
no no it's really not it's definitely
not maybe like a thousand dollars but
what determines it like what kind of um
what do you call like those art art uh
dealer guys that come evaluate the
appraisers appraisal guys right
so is there a license plate appraisal
guy that goes you know what i would i
know you want a 3 million for 30 million
but i'm just going to give you like 20.
i got a guy who specializes in license
plates yeah
and what would be the next level below
that and be like it's not quite mm but i
got something else for you if you're
willing to stick around i got a guy
coming in who can check how do you have
this we go to pawn stars and then that
guy's friend goes i know a guy i know
that one thing i do know is that license
plates like when you go to like car
shows
uh
or like just really large car expos
there's going to be a plates guy or
several of them and they'll have like
plates set up from all kinds like like
it'll be really old
yeah and they have those being sold
really high prices i've never seen
anything like this the last plate that
did sell for quite a lot of money was
the number eleven sold in delaware for
six seventy five thousand six hundred
seventy five thousand yeah somebody and
that's bought somebody paid that for
that
wow just having so much money that's
what you spend your money on yeah this
is ridiculous yeah
how about you donate a charity jerk off
that's the thing it's like to a specific
community that's the flex
so maybe to like me or you walking
around we're not gonna know that that
means anything but it's like a it's like
a nod to somebody else in the hamptons
i'm gonna steal that [ __ ] license
plate if i see it dude yeah 100 percent
[ __ ] and i'm scraping off the qr code
can't you just make your own
customizable but the thing is if
throughout history someone else has
already made it then you can't if you
scrape off the qr code then you don't
own the nft part so that's so dumb yeah
loophole you had us think of that
barbara from shark tank bought it like
rich like you think oh which rich person
who bought this no barb would say she's
out before the deal even starts dude
she's just heard cuz
unless it's a it's a young guy with the
six-pack then she's in love then she's
in yeah she's paying for the hug we all
know that
yeah there's there's actually it's a
lucrative thing where people really uh
they try to amass license plates and
just hold on to them
if you look at autotrader next time
you're at the supermarket you see auto
trader magazine at the checkout flip to
the back all plates
you can just like buy plates i didn't
even know that yeah weird hustle right
do you have a classic plate for your uh
classic stuff i have personalized plates
for all my cars but then they're not uh
they're not old you know how much how
much extra do you pay for that uh
it depends it's it's not only that much
it's such a negligible amount i think
when you go and you want to have your
own plate that says like like s3x or
something like that
yeah so original but the only thing is
that it when you get a personalized play
it just takes like six months to arrive
like it takes forever
did vin diesel have the triple x license
plate in the movie triple x
i don't think he did didn't they didn't
he pull up at one point i'm visualizing
it he pulls up and then they pull the
license plate and it says it says
triplex as well
i think state of the union he did oh
it's david
thank you it wasn't it wasn't him
vin diesel [ __ ] wishes too oh dude i
think he's saving private ryan he did
on a tank
yeah the tank get it 24 million dude
what's the most like ridiculous thing
that you would actually buy and it's
expensive and all of us would judge you
for it i have a [ __ ] nft hoodie you
guys saw my woo hoodies
and i spent a thousand dollars on those
on just one hoodie and it's a [ __ ]
hoodie was a thousand dollars why the
all-white one yeah
and because it's also a [ __ ] nit so
it's not just a hoodie it's also an nft
there was a barcode on it
[Laughter]
that's when it's over uh
they were all they're individually
numbered so they all had their own
number to them and then yeah the nft
exists in the blockchain as long as you
had the entity by a specific date they
took a snapshot of everyone who held it
and then you inserted your address into
a website that could confirm you hold
the nft and they send it to your house
which is pretty fun
so i could okay i can see you spending
money on that is there anything that you
would spend a lot of money on that would
be a niche thing probably a gross amount
of money on a pair of boxing mitts for
my clients how much was the uh was it
like a historical mit did it used to be
owned by eddie bravo or some [ __ ] no it
was a it was made by a very small
japanese man in osaka japan and it's
from a very uh well-renowned company
called winning boxing gloves
and they have the best
quality didn't i give you some winning
one yeah so it's kind of like buying a
hanzo sword yeah and i do actually have
it came with it no i got it i got uh the
pair of myths for like 400 bucks and it
took a year to shift
but that's that's the most expensive
thing that i own probably wow it's
authentic though yeah i'm i usually
don't spend money on you have any
collectibles things that you'd want to
spend that much money on no i usually
spend my money on experiences
i like that me too i should have
my friend says the same thing and he
goes to a lot of rubbing tugs yeah
that's exactly what i was referring to
that's what she made let's change some
lists we'll save some lists after that
right now i have a rare super nintendo
game that's that i put up for sale for
like 500 bucks wait what is it
earthbound no one's about yeah
earthbound yeah oh my god i'm [ __ ]
good it's one of the it's one of the
rarest super nintendo cartridges why is
it so rare like didn't make a lot they
just didn't make a lot of them is the
game actually fun to play yeah but but
it but it got super popular way later in
life oh it's still popular now i never
heard of it is it on the kinders arcade
but it was originally a critical flop
because they just didn't get it i played
it when that game came out i remember
playing that game with my friend bj yeah
you're old and eating pizza bagels hey
[ __ ] you
yeah i'm not i had the [ __ ] cake
he's old for it
that's a great game that's a really
well-written game too really impressed
that you know that much about it it's
[ __ ] cool i know oh yeah it's a
masterpiece he's like you want to buy it
that's the game that ness is from oh
she knows because she's a smash brothers
[ __ ] professional by the way are you
an s she's like a pro level smash player
i don't know if you're that good because
you will kick my ass i'll tell you that
right now
and then she just got so good that i
started hating all women who's your
character
whoa whoa whoa whoa
not over here that won't fly who's your
favorite super smash character um my
main is zelda right now oh [ __ ] right
now she doesn't [ __ ] around
right now no it's it's always been zelda
i know it was like corn for a little bit
yeah
i found my way my main is star fox
mccloud dude i'll [ __ ] you up
and guess what i'm more of a captain
falco kind of guy
yeah you better watch out dude did you
spend a lot of money on your suit of
armor
samurai armor you don't have to say how
much it was but like i've not only yeah
i spent a lot of money on stupid [ __ ]
they don't even exist here anymore no
that case alone was like 10 little over
10 grand to make custom and then the
armor
the case was to pre like to display it
was more expensive than the samurai
arbor itself
i wouldn't even give you 500 for that
the samurai was like 800 bucks no no 8
000 8 000.
8 000.
that came that and you know i had a tea
room yeah in my other office i gave it
to my friend
yeah i spent 20 grand building package
his office used to look like a
traditional japanese tea room
it was so
dope but talk about depreciating asset
right like it's gone but do you enjoy it
i enjoyed it for the time being now my
friend's enjoying it because you know
his roommate's sleeping in it so yeah
he's like hates it
how about this i got twenty five
thousand dollar [ __ ] nft hood uh nft
dragon that i bought oh the dragon egg
yeah my [ __ ] dragon eggs i don't even
know what that [ __ ] that would be worth
at all
i remember no if it was an asteroid
first right yeah and it turned into a
track
no it was an astral hey why are you
laughing at me dude you bought a [ __ ]
suit armor for 10 grand i know because
we're this is why we're friends right
that was the case this is why we're
we're not even though
i think we're still very serious this is
the truth man it's my [ __ ] truth and
my reality
but yeah dude
so they have this like meteor shower and
then yeah they it would crack that you
cracked the virtual right that's yeah
it's like a tamagotchi but it's cool nft
so that you get the meteor and it's a
tea and then you turn that you open that
up and it becomes either dust or dragon
so the best thing was like me and
anthony bought him at the same time and
of course i got a [ __ ] dragon that he
got [ __ ] dust
and so then
but what can you do with the dust you
can like use it to customize [ __ ] or
something i don't know it's pretty whack
honestly
but the dragon eggs were sick and then
the dragon eggs like right now if you
nested them by a certain time then you
can open them when they when they
release the dragons but they're not
releasing them yet um
but if you didn't
do it in time which anthony didn't
you lose it so he bought an egg in the
aftermarket and now he's not even gonna
get to [ __ ] ever open it and i didn't
tell him yet because i because i didn't
get to tell him to his face i wanted to
be able to see his face when i tell him
have him just watch this clip
but anthony we want to show you
something real quick so anthony now that
you know oh my god comment below what
you think anthony
[Music]
[Applause]
you